[SWOOSH]
[HEARTBEAT]
NARRATOR: A strange invisible
assassin stalks its prey.
It attacks and hijacks the
cell forcing it to produce
hundreds of new raiders.
This is what happens when
the microcosmos turns on us.
In 2020, we experienced
this invasion of the body
snatchers first hand.
A tiny virus caused a
global pandemic, COVID-19.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: This pandemic
makes me see the world
completely differently
because there
was an invisible universe, one
that covers me and is within me
that I pretty much
ignored for the most part.
NARRATOR: Maybe we ignore this
other universe because it's
invisible to the naked eye.
PHIL PLAIT: We live in a
largely invisible universe.
We can't see everything
that's going on.
Some of the biggest stuff
we can't see very well.
And in fact, a lot of
the littlest stuff,
we can't either.
Just because something
is too small to see
doesn't mean it's not important.
In fact, very, very
tiny things have
a huge impact on our lives.
[SWOOSH]
NARRATOR: Some of these
impacts are beneficial
but they're overshadowed by the
devastating effects of disease.
LEWIS DARTNELL:
The longest running
conflict that humanity
has engaged in
is that against the microcosmos.
Our long running battle
against bacteria and viruses,
they're trying to kill us.
NARRATOR: A century ago,
we faced the Spanish flu.
CARLY HOWETT: This absolutely
annihilated Europe.
At the time, it caused millions
upon millions of deaths.
So this is definitely
not the first pandemic,
it quite frankly, probably
isn't the last one.
In a way, the
Coronavirus has forced
us to come to a
greater understanding
of the microscopic world.
NARRATOR: The
microcosmos is complex.
While some parts kill
us, others keep us alive.
CARLY HOWETT: The microcosmos
is important for us to survive,
in order for us to
do all of the things
that our bodies
does, in order for us
to live and grow and thrive.
Our lives depend
on the microcosmos.
The air we breathe and the
surface of the earth around us
has been profoundly
affected by the microcosmos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: The invisible
microcosmos operates
in every part of the world.
This world that you
can't see is everywhere
from geothermal hot springs,
to glaciers, to deep sea
hydrothermal vent systems.
NARRATOR: We have discovered
that every cubic foot
of Earth's atmosphere
and its oceans
contain millions of viruses.
JANE RADEBAUGH: There are
more viruses here on Earth
than there are stars
in the universe.
That's incredible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Even though
there are around 1, 400
the thickness of human
hair, stuck end-to-end,
all the viruses on
Earth would stretch
100 million light years.
That's 40 times the distance
to our neighboring galaxy,
Andromeda.
JANE RADEBAUGH: That
really makes us ask,
whose planet is this anyway?
If you just added this
up by sheer numbers,
you would say this
is the virus planet.
NARRATOR: The microcosmos has
also taken over our bodies.
We're only partly human.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARLY HOWETT: The fact that
so little of my own body,
of everyone's body is
as human cells kind
of leaves you wondering, what's
the rest of it made of, right?
It is astonishing
that we share our bodies
with over 380 trillion viruses.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: And over 39
trillion bacterial cells.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: The average
human has more bacterial cells
inside their body than there are
human cells inside their body.
So what are we really?
There are moments in
the history of science
that I actually remember where I
was when they When for example,
we detected two colliding black
holes or something like that,
but another one was when I
realized that almost half
our body is actually not human.
I mean that is crazy.
For people that are
scared of bacteria,
that's a really interesting
thing to know, right?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Bacteria help us
digest food, produce vitamins
and even influence our mood.
But what are they?
Bacteria are single celled
organisms with a cell wall
and a central nucleus containing
genetic material, RNA or DNA.
They can move around
and replicate.
[BLOOD GUSHING]
Viruses are
completely different.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE THALLER:
In the universe,
there are some
mysteries that have
actually personally
made me kind of pause
and give me goosebumps.
And strangely enough,
one of them is viruses.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The mystery is how
viruses can have
so much impact on the world
despite their tiny size
and apparent simplicity.
[BLOOD GUSHING]
Most are just a strand of
genetic material sometimes
encased in a shell of protein.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And compared to
bacteria which behave kind
of like other normal cells
that we're used to some degree,
viruses are very strange.
We don't really
understand viruses.
We don't even know if
they're alive or not.
The question are
viruses alive is
actually more difficult to
answer than you might think.
What is the definition of life?
What does it mean to be alive?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: NASA's
definition of life
is a self-sustained
chemical system
capable of Darwinian evolution.
Entities that feed make
energy and reproduce.
Viruses can't do
that on their own.
They have to have a
host cell to do that.
They have the genetic
material that they
need but none of the machinery.
So they really have to infect a
host, if not, they're useless.
[BLOOD GUSHING]
MAN: Inside's a host's body,
viruses latch on to the surface
of cells and then take control.
A virus' life
cycle is effectively
to hack another cell.
They have to inject that
genetic material into a living
cell, and then the cell
is hijacked and starts
making copies of the virus.
LEWIS DARTNELL: Which then
have to burst out of this cell
almost literally like that
gory, grotesque scene in aliens.
They burst out
from the inside.
That's like a cellular
level horrible.
[BLOOD GUSHING]
NARRATOR: This method of
replicating is chilling.
It doesn't answer the question
of whether they're alive.
That uncertainty may influence
our search for life in space.
KATHRYN BYWATERS: One of
the interesting things
to think about is
if we found a virus
on another planetary surface,
would we classify that as life?
Would we say that
we have found life?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: We don't know.
But space viruses
could be a sign
of other extraterrestrial
life forms.
KATHRYN BYWATERS: Viruses to
have a host cell to replicate.
So if you find a virus, in
essence you've found life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Viruses might lead
us to extraterrestrial life.
Now, new research suggests
that life on Earth
may have come from
space, brought
to us in a cosmic bombardment
when our planet was young.